all right but if you do like to drink
especially as we think about celebrating
the New Year we're taking a look at one
of the world's great spirits rum it's
traditionally made from sugarcane or
molasses but up until the Revolutionary
War it was at the center of colonial
life in America but it was eventually
overtaken in popularity by Spirits like
whiskey vodka and tequila so we set out
to find out why that happened and sipped
our way through a range of rums
including one that's been made by the
same family for more than 160 years
a taste of rum might invoke images of
pirates or the memory of a bad hangover
but those tropes don't paint a full
picture of the spirit
just ask Anton kinloch
250 rums line the shelves of fuchsia his
Tiki Bar in New Paltz New York this one
is aged for eight years in French Oak
from a French style rum agricole which
is distilled from sugarcane juice
instead of molasses it is like an angel
dancing on the tip of my tongue that's a
great way to describe it to a Japanese
rum aged in stainless steel tanks feels
like rice and seaweed this doesn't even
taste like rum at least rum as I know it
despite its diversity rum's popularity
in the United States falls short
compared to that of other Liquors its
consumption declined between 2020 and
2021 clocking in at a third of vodkas
rum is still lagging behind explain that
to me there is this stigma that it is
naturally sweet and then it goes in
sweet drinks rum is not inherently Sweet
It Is inherently dry like every other
Spirit on the market to understand the
status of rum today we decided to unpack
its beginning things and turn to
mixologists and Spirits expert Shannon
mustafer what have you made for us today
you are enjoying the plantier which is a
wonderful variation on the rum punch all
right
she explained that rum's presence in the
west dates back to the 17th century how
much was rum a part of piracy on the
high seas departs aren't really into rum
as much as they were into any commodity
that they could kind of you know get
their hands on rum was distilled from
the waste of one of the most valuable
Commodities in the world at the time
sugar millions of enslaved people were
bought to the colonies to sustain its
production the revenue that was
generated by the sugar trade
was equivalent to what we experienced in
the age of the gold rush so you know rum
is tied to economics different political
shifts by 1790 the French had brought
half a million enslaved people to its
Colony senomang now known as Haiti
inspired by the French Revolution they
revolted to France went to war with this
tiny little island they also went to war
economically so they kind of imposed the
sanction of sorts by funding the beet
sugar industry as an alternative that
also impacted the rum industry in 1804
Haiti gained its independence and the
world's first black LED Republic was
born
six decades later Frenchman Duprey
barbancore founded a rum Distillery on
the island the thing that's really cool
about from Barbacoa is that the family
has been able to maintain an operation
in spite of all the upheaval and the
island Delphine Gardere is the fifth
generation of her family to become its
CEO we met her to discuss 160 years of
rum tradition over a classic Haitian
meal prepared by Chef Wesley Seymour at
his restaurant Zumi first of all I love
this bottle I love this packaging right
because it is so Haitian I mean it's
beautiful how long has it been like this
for this 15 years since the 60s and this
was actually a painting that was at the
office wow it's a Haitian painting by an
artist called Felix Jones why they have
ranked barbancore as one of the world's
great runs is the method that you
distill the sugar cane we distilled at a
higher degree than actually the French
rums we have a very long fermentation
which gives our rum a light later and
spicier notes we know the situation that
Haiti is in right now it's terrible why
are you still in Haiti I have over 600
employees we have a clinic with
Pediatrics if I were to leave then who
else is going to start playing that role
back at fuchsia Anton hopes to dispel
customers concerns about Rum by offering
them favorites with a Twist usually I
will lay down some very basic questions
what Spirits do they normally enjoy and
simply substitute a rum that might hit
all those targets I've never had a rum
Manhattan can I try one I would love to
make that
[Music]
cheers
that is absolutely delicious it has all
the flavor profiles of Manhattan except
that one unique flavor that the rum
brings to it so hopefully we can
convince people to now look at rum as of
more legitimate spirits
so a couple of things to share about
barbancore in 2021 it won a gold medal
at the San Francisco World Spirits
competition it has now won 50 medals
since its founding in 1862 and I love
what Delphine told me about staying in
Haiti and keeping the means of
production in Haiti through all the
political upheaval calamities this
company and people like Delphine are
keeping the spirits alive of many many
people on the island and the diaspora
um rum has its Colonial upbringings but
there are people like Mark Farrell who
Michelle Miller profiled who's got a rum
called ten to one
they're bringing it out of its Colonial
Beginnings right and into the modern era
that was a great piece and I love that
you're you're highlighting rum from
Haiti right I mean you know one of the
things that the rum that comes from
Haiti rum agricult and many other rums
are like cognacs they're not necessarily
meant to be mixed in cocktails they're
meant to be I did not know the same way
you sip a cognac we'll have we'll have
some in February after dry January